en este vídeo vamos a profundizar un
poco en la idea de lo que significa un
monopolio y para ayudarnos a apreciar
eso pensemos en el espectro en el que
pueden estar las empresas así que este
va a ser mi espectro ahora en el extremo
izquierdo podemos imaginar la
competencia perfecta idealizada
competencia perfecta y hemos hablado de
eso en otros vídeos pero solo como un
repaso aquí es donde hay muchas empresas
aquí es donde se vende un producto o
servicio homogéneo las empresas aquí no
tienen barreras para entrar o salir del
mercado así que no hay barreras para
entrar o salir estas empresas de las que
hemos hablado en otros vídeos deben ser
precio aceptantes porque son precio
aceptantes bueno cualquiera que sea el
precio de mercado y debido a que nadie
le importa de cuál de estas empresas se
obtiene el producto ninguna de esas
empresas puede realmente fijar su propio
precio si vendieran por encima del
precio del mercado bueno entonces nadie
les compraría por lo que sólo serán
precio aceptantes y otra cosa que
asumimos
de la competencia perfecta es que todos
los actores en el mercado a ambos tanto
los compradores que son muchos y los
vendedores que son muchos
todos saben cuáles son las transacciones
que se están realizando existe
información perfecta saben quién está
vendiendo a quién y por qué cantidad
ahora el otro extremo aquí es donde
tenemos el monopolio el monopolio aquí
en lugar de que muchas empresas vendan o
muchas empresas produzcan tiene
solamente una empresa productora en
lugar de un producto homogéneo bueno en
este caso es la única empresa en lugar
de no existir las barreras a la entrada
o la salida del mercado aquí tenemos
exactamente lo contrario por lo que
podría decirse barreras insuperables
especialmente para entrar al mercado y
en lugar de ser un precio aceptan te
eres un fijador de precios fijador de
precios eres el único jugador eres el
único actor que está vendiendo algo así
que puedes decidir a qué precio venderlo
ahora la competencia perfecta como lo he
dicho es una
teórica es difícil decir que algún
mercado es absolutamente perfecto pero
podemos imaginar mercados que están en
este espectro algunos más cerca de la
competencia perfecta otros más cerca de
un monopolio lo que puedo imaginar que
está más cerca de la competencia
perfecta podría ser digamos la
agricultura o un cierto tipo de
agricultura digamos que compras
pistaches y la mayoría de las personas
se muestran indiferentes con respecto a
la procedencia de sus pistaches aunque
algunas personas pueden discrepar de que
ciertos tipos de pistaches son mejores
que otros pero en su mayor parte esto
está más cerca de la competencia
perfecta habrá sólo un precio en el
mercado de pistaches si alguien quiere
cultivar pistaches no estoy
familiarizada con lo que se necesita
para cultivar pistaches y me disculpo
por cualquier ofensa a los productores
de pistaches que hay por ahí pero tal
vez sólo requieran obtener suficiente
tierra y hay muy pocas barreras para
entrar y empezar a producir pistaches
como mencioné muchos lo percibirían como
un producto
entre los productores y digamos que
podría haber muchas empresas en el
mercado de pistaches realmente no sé si
ese es el caso pero supongamos que si
ese fuera el caso estaría más cerca de
una competencia perfecta ahora como un
monopolio puedes imaginar cosas que
requieren mucha infraestructura para
hacer ese servicio así que puedo
imaginar cosas aquí cerca del monopolio
o en el monopolio como proveedores de
servicios públicos donde es difícil que
varias personas conecten las líneas
eléctricas a las casas puedes imaginar
cosas como esta proveedores de
telecomunicaciones pueden estar cerca
aunque la mayoría de las geografías
tiene más de un proveedor de
telecomunicaciones hay algunas partes
del mundo que solo tienen uno porque una
vez más hay barreras muy muy altas a la
entrada del mercado tienes que lanzar
satélites y poner el cable bajo tierra y
desenterrar carreteras y lo que sea
hasta que te acercas más y más a esta
idea de que tal vez haya sólo una
empresa
si te encuentras en una situación como
las telecomunicaciones en muchos de los
lugares donde solo hay un puñado de
empresas se le conoce como oligopolio
pero pensemos en el extremo cuando estás
en una situación de monopolio en los
próximos vídeos vamos a profundizar un
poco más en lo que significa hacer un
monopolio y cuál es la cantidad racional
para que produzca una empresa monopólica
que maximiza las ganancias y cuál sería
su ganancia económica